all right chris
chris where'd you grow up where are you
from originally um
well i'm from portland oregon
um what else you want to know
tell me about your family you had both
your both your parents oh
well growing up
my mom and dad
well they were they were cool they got
along pretty well
uh my father was a bit of a drinker my
mom
likes to smoke pot um
they comply with
each other uh
get along how would you describe your
childhood
what were you saying how would you
describe your childhood
um it was decent
no abuse nothing crazy going on no abuse
nothing crazy going on
good how far did you go in school
um went to high school
you graduated yeah
what'd you do after school after high
school
um well
after high school i didn't do nothing
much
i worked some jobs
smoked a lot of weed
um
[Music]
drank alcohol tripped on lsd
god what age
acid uh
different types of drugs what age were
you when you started
using drugs oh 15 15.
no that was pot or that was the harder
drinks just pie
just fun and then the bath salts and the
lsd
and the that's
acid started for you when
what were you saying the harder drugs
that you were using
you started using at what age oh
well
doing the acid when i was
like 18.
how do you know
[Music]
um 24 now
what drugs are you using today
um been using crystal meth
for some time
smoking weed still drinking alcohol
yeah and where do you live
where do you stay
um well i was staying in san diego on
probation but now i came out here
i was on uh
[Music]
i was on terms with the crisis house out
there but i was getting tired of the
knife out there
going with the
just schizophrenia oh you have
schizophrenia yeah and are you taking
medications for that or have you had
medications for that
um yeah i've got
exact practices for it
are you taking them currently
oh no
was the last time you spoke to your
family
oh
last time i spoke to him
was uh back when i was in san diego
so it's been a while
and how do you support yourself now oh
um
well right now i'm just stealing stuff
to get money
stealing clothes
and selling selling into a fence oh what
you resell them you sell the strong
items to a fence
i sell them or
or keep them
you have any friends chris
yeah i've got friends back in utah
some out here in california
[Music]
what's been the lowest point of your
life
um
i would say now right now it'll make
sense
yeah dealing with schizophrenia is going
to be very difficult right
yeah i think if you're not taking the
medications
you can just spiral downward and makes
it hard to even get your
life together again right
you were saying dealing with
schizophrenia must be very difficult
especially if you're not taking the
medication oh it's not
difficult to deal with it can be though
yeah are you taking the medications
currently
um no
and are you staying in a tent here in
skid row or no i understand on the
streets you're just on the street
without a 10.
do you have goals of what you'd like to
do in your life or anything like that
um
try to get some gr
out here ryan got no id or nothing
government release
do you see any hope for getting off the
streets and
anywhere i mean do you see your family
coming to help you or anything like that
um you're saying what sorry do you have
any hope of getting off the streets
do you see any any solution to your
situation
um well
no but maybe
i don't know maybe there's help for me
yeah there's a there's quite a few
mental health
programs that are down here you might be
able to
get some help with your medications and
stabilize your life a little bit
have you considered going to one of
those programs
um you probably walk past them every day
yeah i don't know what programs you're
seeing like
i can direct you to some of them if you
like okay we're done
what uh what would you say is the most
important thing you've learned in your
life
respect
respect's a good one that's important
for yourself and everyone else too all
right
all right chris well thank you for
talking with me
and i'm gonna try to get you some help
so maybe you can get
some medications for your schizophrenia
okay all right all right
thank you very much